- All right, so we
always like to close out
with something trending online
that might make you smile.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
So I recently dropped a couple songs
off my upcoming album "Chemistry"
and I'm super excited about it,
but this is my favorite thing
to happen since I released it.
It also led to something
I did not see coming.
Apparently Australian singer, Troye Sivan
thought I was calling him
out in my song "Mine."
I died, you guys, when I
saw this, I laughed so hard.
Somebody sent it to me, I'd just woken up.
I laughed so hard alone in
my house, belly laughed.
Just look at what he posted on TikTok.
- What did I do to upset Kelly Clarkson?
♪ Troye Sivan ♪
♪ Who the hell do you think you are? ♪
(audience cheering)
It's hands down my favorite thing
that's ever happened
with releasing a song.
I cannot not think of him
when I sing this song now.
Every time I'm like
Troye Sivan, every time.
To be clear, I did not sing his name.
I don't know why it sounds like that,
but the line is "your choice of art."
And I guess it's just so high, right?
It just, I don't know,
it's just I sound a little
and who the hell do you
think you are is the line.
But I have Troye on the
line to clear things up.
He watches on 7 Bravo.
What's up, man?
(audience cheering)
You are, first of all,
I've already been a fan,
but man, you are the funniest human.
Sorry for the mix up.
How did you find that out?
How did you hear that?
- Well, first of all,
I'm sorry to be meeting
this way with like a fight.
You know what I mean?
'Cause I love you so much
and I have for so long.
But no, my friend texted it to me
and literally was like, "What did you do?
How did you upset Kelly Clarkson?"
And I watched it
and just immediately I
had the same reaction.
I was like belly laughing
'cause it's so scary.
You're so sincere when you sing it as well
that I was like, "Oh
my God, what did I do?"
But, and then I immediately
like opened TikTok
and made the TikTok.
- Oh my god, it was hilarious.
And thank you so much.
I laughed so hard I worked out.
Anyway, I hear you that
you have a lot of projects
going on these days, so
tell me what you're up to.
- I do, yeah.
My album is pretty much done.
So that's coming out soon.
- Yeah!
- I'm also on a TV show on HBO
that's called "The Idol"
that's coming out in June.
So very excited.
- [Kelly] That's incredible.
- I'm gonna make this my
theme song by the way.
Anytime I do any promo or
anything for any of that,
it's gonna play your song.
I'm gonna make people do that.
- Oh my god, I love it so much.
I literally, man,
I played a show the other
night playing my whole record
and like right when it comes, like,
I can't not think of you.
And then I have to be like, don't laugh.
It's not a funny part emotionally,
but it's the funniest thing ever.
Anyway, thank you so much, Troye.
There probably so much joy.
I promise, we're cool.
We're not in a fight.
I'm liking your post right now.
I can't wait for your music, man.
(audience cheering)
- [Troye] Thank you so much.
- Absolutely.
Well, okay, so usually this is the point
we give our guest $1,000
courtesy of our season
long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of FriXion, the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show."
But as you just heard,
Troye's doing pretty well for himself.
He's all right, so he doesn't need it.
So we're giving the money
to someone in the audience.
(audience cheering)
So, it's actually taped
beneath one of your chairs.
So we don't know who has it right now.
So who has it?
- What?
(audience cheering)
- Stand up.
- Oh my God.
- First of all, you are adorable
with your little fanny pack.
- Thank you.
- I like it.
- Thank you so much.
- It's so nineties, your vibe right now.
What's your name?
- My name is Charlene.
- So what are you gonna do?
Don't just spend it on bills.
Spend a little on bills,
then have fun with it.
What would you spend it on?
- I'm like school.
I'm finishing my bachelor's right now.
My goal is to get my master's in nursing.
- [Kelly] That's incredible.
That's incredible.
- I probably will spend it on school.
- Actually, that's probably
a smart decision, Charlene.
Thank you so much for coming.
All right, thank you to
all our guests this hour.
Bebe Rexha, Oliver Stark,
Jeff, Kelly, Chief Michael,
Julie Cornell, Quanesia Frasier,
and all our friends at KETV
Newswatch Channel Seven.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.